so this question we can not use if you
don't want me to I'm gonna just say it
now so for did wordplay make you a
millionaire no no wordplay did not make
us a millionaire we we that's funny you
to ask that because when we that was our
first film and we took it to we got
accepted to Sundance
in 2006 took it to the festival and
there was a very intense bidding war for
that film we ended up with seven seven
offers on the table from you know all
the big distributors and we sold it for
a million dollars we only we had only
spent a little over a hundred thousand
dollars to get the movie to Sundance
okay so we spent a year making it we
spent about a hundred thousand dollars
and change to make that cut of the film
and we sold it for a million bucks and I
remember telling our agent at Sundance
our agent is john schloss from cinetic
media i said i'm really worried about
selling our film for a million dollars
I'm afraid that I'm afraid that you know
we're gonna be one of those infamous
films that come out of Sundance like oh
they paid too much and that movie
underperformed and like I didn't wanna I
didn't want to have all that I was like
we should sell it for less he's like no
he's like first of all a million dollars
is not that much money for a movie
he's like you've made a really good film
that a lot of people want to see so
that's that's the right price and and
you know and you have it it's it's we
already have a deal we already shook
hands on this deal what I didn't know
was that when after Sundance you know
Sundance is in January and we were in
theaters we were in about five hundred
theaters that summer in June we came out
in June later on
here we had a lot of work to do on the
film between selling it and releasing it
we had to film out we had to pay for
that there's a hundred thousand dollars
and over a hundred thousand dollars to
film out we had to license all the music
we did a lot more graphics we did a lot
more editing I mean it really started to
add up and by the time we were sitting
in the theaters on opening night at the
IFC Center in New York City we had spent
a total of almost seven hundred thousand
dollars so do the math we walked away
with three hundred thousand dollars now
that's great I mean if I could do that
if I could do that every year I would do
I would do that every year unfortunately
that's that's that's not what normally
happens I think on a lot of these films
I mean I hate to say it because it
sounds really discouraging but I think
on a lot of these documentaries you're
lucky even to break even and what we're
finding nowadays is that if you don't
have if you don't have good partners
when you go out to make these films
you're really gonna be in trouble on
this film we had on if you build it we
had great partners the Sundance was a
big partner the John D and Catherine T
MacArthur Foundation film independent
the Candida foundation which is out of
the East Coast the wind coat foundation
we did a Kickstarter campaign we want an
Independent Spirit Award we won the
bright future award presented by
Unilever project sunlight that was a
$25,000 award that we won I mean we had
an army behind us really to make this
film if we didn't have that we probably
wouldn't be sitting here in my house
because we probably would have lost our
house we probably had to sell our house
I mean it was so financially challenging
for us to make this film
Christina and I and our partner Neil
bear you know we we've been at this a
long time we've been making movies and
Neil's up tremendously successful
television writer and showrunner and we
thought we had it all figured out and
then we made this movie about a small
town in North Carolina that took three
years to make and it was hard to raise
money I'm it was challenging so you know
wordplay was great and we made money on
that film and we also sort of launched
our film careers at the same time but I
think more often than not these movies
you do them for other than financial
reasons and if you are lucky enough to
make money on a film more often than not
you fold that into your next project and
it's tied up in the next one so yeah
it's it's great if anyone is thinking
about like becoming a millionaire
I wouldn't recommend making documentary
films because it it's very unusual that
that would be the case it could happen
but more often than not it won't so
knowing that there were some times when
you could have come close to losing many
things how did you get through that were
there sleepless nights whether in times
when you really had to just go for a
walk around the block and say okay
what's my focus why am I doing this well
we started making if he build it in
summer of 2010 we were hoping to be to
be done to have the movie out there at
festivals in early 2012 it it took a
year longer than we thought so
throughout all of 2012 we were still
making the movie we weren't you know
releasing it and putting it out in the
world so yeah it was an extra 12 months
that we had not planned that we had not
budgeted for the story kept going the
editing was harder than we thought it
would be because the story was really
fairly complex and there were a lot of
nuances that took a long time to figure
out and so we spent all of 2012 on this
film and we didn't make any money at all
not a penny we were trying to raise
money and we were trying to get other
partners but that had stalled so it was
tough I mean that was tough but you know
we got through it and and called in a
lot of favors and and luckily there was
a very happy ending as soon as the film
premiered at the full-frame Film
Festival in April of 2013 literally that
evening we we got one partner that
brought a very significant grant Barrett
the biggest grant we got for the project
there was another prop there was another
partner that we met through something
called good pitch which is a program
between Brit Docs and Sundance they they
do these pitches around the world you
bring five films together and their
filmmaking teams and you bring them into
a theater or an arena and everyone in
the crowd is a funder or a foundation or
a broadcaster or somebody that might be
interested in your project and we got a
very large grant that came out of good
pitch as well so yeah I mean it was a
squeaker I don't know how else to say it
it was really hard to get this film done
but we made it and we loved it so it was
worth it
you